[موسيقى]
بضربات وقصف متبادل بين الجيش التركي وما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه يسخن المشهد
على طول الحدود السوريه التركيه داخل
الاراضي التركيه وقرب الحدود مع سوريا
سقطت قذائف فوق الضحايا قالت انقره انما
اصدرها منتصفهم بالمنظمات الارهابيه في
اشاره لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وزاره الدفاع التركيه قالت ان قواتها ردت
قصف المدفعيين على تلك الهجمات كما نفذ
الجيش التركي ضربات جويه استخدمت فيها
المسيارات وسائل الاعلام مواليد لما
تعرفوا بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ذكرت ان
الضربات التركيه
الرئيس التركي رجب اردوغان ووزير داخليته
اشاره الى احتمال الا يقتصر رد القوات
التركيه على القصف المدفعي والضرابات
الجويه بل قد يمتد الى عمليه عسكريه بريه
في شمال سوريا فانقر تصنف بعض مكونات قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه والتي تسيطر على مناطق
واسعاره شرقيه وشمال شرقي سوريا على انها
نسخه وامتداد حزب العمال الكردستاني
المصنف ارهابيا وتلك القوات مكونه من
فصائل يشكل المسلحون الاكراد الاغلبيه
فيها كوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه ووحدات
حمايه المراه اضافه الى فصائل اخرى
مقاتلوها من ابناء المنطقه العرب
والسوريان وغيرهم اشاره المسؤولين الاتراك
الى احتمال قيام الجيش التركي بعمليه بريه
شماليه سوريا لها حساباتها فالولايات
المتحده تدعم ما تسمى بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه خصوصا في معاركها ضد تنظيم
الدوله لكن رغم ذلك فان الجيش التركي قام
خلال السنوات الاخيره بعمليات عسكريه
كبيره تمكن خلالها من اخراج المسلحين
الاكراد من المناطق حدوديه سوريه وبعمق
عشرات الكيلومترات